[Music]
having never dyed my hair I'm no dyeing
my hair so we'll see what what it's
about
not very nervous not very excited afraid
it's gonna hurt feels like my head's
being painted I really hope my hair
doesn't fall out because I super bleach
it at home but I have really great
expectations for this like I can't wait
to have gray hair feels great right now
so have you thanked ladies
tracking me from the fact that bleaching
my hair like Disney villain so I have
pretty high expectations I don't have my
glasses on so I can't really see myself
but what I can see I feel like I look
like Cisco I can see a kind of bond in
order to go gray you need to lift their
hair to the latest yellow blonde
possible no way possibly get it that
late in one shot what song are we doing
round 2 of the bleaching uh-huh
feels like play-doh in a plastic bag
it's pretty crazy right now
well the liner does strip the hair from
everything that was in the hair strand
with the note 3 that we put in the color
helps deposit into protein conditioning
agents so even though we're stripping
out like a pigment we're still adding in
proteins and things to keep your hair
strong I think I'm tearing up that's 7
I'm feeling pretty good right now so no
no I'm not crying like Leah feels like a
practical joke right now you ever need
to apologize for how labor-intensive it
is I thought it was gonna be way easier
to kind of like a 1/2 and go but no
we've been here for things like 3 hours
now finally putting it in the grave I
don't know where I am right now so many
chemicals I'm really excited I mean this
is just the set so I don't know you
never know till it's all done this bugs
the most surreal for getting my hair cut
and just having the hair falling off
being gay is super strange I mean to
think about the fact that just when I
came in my hair was black and now is
gray it's kind of impressive because
it's almost like magic like I was a
super light haired girl so it was easier
for them
but I couldn't imagine what it's like
for a dark-haired person I have had
thoughts about whether this is like some
senior cultural appropriation that's
crazy I'm ready to take this granny here
in the world
chef's some whippersnappers how it's
done I'm really well done my hair feels
healthier than before you know before I
came in so it's great
I'm a fan it's definitely different and
I don't know if I would like do it again
because I take so much a long time to do
it so I definitely appreciate it will
that actually do this for fun or for any
reason it's fun felt like I was getting
my hair wash for like 4 hours straight
I'm into it but damn do I look good
I'm sorry I love it I've been an amazing
job you're like I have a whole life
ahead of me even though I look like kind
of 80
[Music]